welcome to another edition of a beginner
breakdown am your host Mike hummer back
from a vacation in a while working
vacation rate in beautiful Phoenix
Arizona I got to live like the Duke of
Earl down there I got to a clam a big
mound and this is the view from the top
alright so it was a lot of fun and then
after the event i got to hang out with
the US open champion alexander schäuble
of eight and a half out of nine had a
lot of fun and and there's a lawrence as
well so it was a lot of fun but we do
have some unfinished business here i
finally located the puzzle the mystery
puzzle from the national open ok so here
it is there's two experts playing it is
black to move in this position and i
instantly see the wind white obviously
just played the move and this is a big
hit removing his rook from the back row
2 i'm going to attack your queen alright
so yet true he's attacking our queen a
nine-point piece but we can we can do a
slammer here all right does anybody have
any ideas obviously the expert couldn't
couldn't find the move i went up after
the game and told hey you know you could
easily had a win here obviously a flax
winning no matter what he plays notice a
whites queen is also under attack but we
don't want to trade because that really
doesn't get us anywhere right
really well we can do whatever but okay
but that's not what we want to do so so
big hit right black just moved his rook
off of the back row leaving his back row
vulnerable right all right adjourn right
good Yeah Yeah right right so you had
you have the move move after all these
hints okay what about adjourns our
Father Queen a one Quinn a one
unfortunately doesn't work because Queen
takes rook Queen takes check and then
well let's say check and still doesn't
work
but we're getting there we're getting
ideas we're getting ideas yes Kevin
rookie one yes try just try to defend
the checkmate yeah it's impossible as
you can play Queen takes e6 check just
for fun but but yeah game over because I
was your Kim can't to protect this pawn
can't move this rook can't move rook to
be one would actually be the best move
in that position so so that's that and
that's the pause i promise you but now
we're going to look at a tournament that
adjourn won the Royal Rumble bash okay
so here's a game from the Royal Rumble
bash we got Montaigne against akshay
alright so it's been a while since this
this term is taking place and can't
remember what happened so you'll be just
as shocked as me okay so okay yeah you
know you know this result adjourn now oh
really okay so so a word on the street
is actually plays a pretty mean game so
I'm thinking that akshay is probably the
winner in this game especially cuz up
top it says 01 so so okay so actually so
let's watch it from the heroes
perspective then okay akshay okay so e4
e5 Knight f3 knight c6 Knight to c3 okay
a little bit passive doesn't help
develop your queen side or your King
side as well alright so we have taxed
the night Bishop attacks the night so it
wasn't bluffing he's going to take it
and double the pawns but first he plays
Bishop takes which is obviously a
mistake because now black has an
intermezzo right how does black easily
win upon in this position a journey
Bishop takes D to check I can't check
you because I'm in check right so after
Queen takes
just take good now he takes this all
right and then we got no how about how
about right here how about right here
you're going to play there
yeah we're there yeah yeah black ones
upon by right after d6 right if you dumb
enough to go there check oh what a sexy
right right but we'll just slide d6 and
okay so we're going to whip on it's been
decided okay so let's see if he can
figure this out I can't okay so takes
takes Knight attacks the pawn so they
attack back Bishop ends the night
excellent castles it gets castle as well
h3 obviously black should play Bishop h5
he does and he takes the pin piece and
let's see if it works out so it works
out in this variation because you want
to take a pin piece when you're going to
win material obviously he has one two
three defenders of the pond but two
attackers we erase one if you really
want to save a spawn he could take like
that but who really wants their King
looking like that anybody no no so so
Queen takes up three takes takes and now
we'll take and black is looking pretty
good and what is obviously under attack
in this position because remember just
because you took a piece doesn't mean
you don't have ulterior motives for
wanting to be on that square right so II
for ya sorry for is under attack adjourn
what else is under attack e 1 a 1 so
let's move the bish up to a three or
something or g5 or anywhere instead he
attacks and see your rook and queen goes
their attacks upon it and we attack the
night hey got the pawn back let's see if
it's going to be enough compensation for
that rook I don't think it's going to be
either 86 Queen takes another
ponceau he's getting some things back
alright so this was a good move by my
black here he picked the right rook
because if well so if work takes here
obviously we'll have another intermezzo
and we'll get that no questions at this
time all right so uh uh what is your
comment adjourn yeah well that's why
that's right let's just let you see it
to believe it alright so we took it and
obviously it happened just as foreseen
check is always good to check check and
then yeah you've been even white here he
sees he sees the mate right he sees the
mate coming up bring another attacker in
oh alright adjourn season even cooler
checkmate Knight takes g3 check boot yup
alright so then maybe not the best game
maybe not the best game but um so so as
as we see we're going to see a lot of
bad moves tonight but uh but then I'm
going to shock you with the worst move
and you're gonna be like wow that was
the worst move of all these moves and it
was like it really was okay so well
let's see uh mr. uh Jerome against Jacob
I'm going to bet that uh it's not it's
not the Jacob you're thinking of it's a
Jacob that played in the world workable
bash okay all right so uh the Rome's got
all the white pieces alright yeah so
just attack yeah I like all right so
take take a attacks it goes back to d6 I
prefer just going all the way back to d8
but that's fine all right Knight f3 c6
Bishop e2 so so look at that a
Scholastic player playing Bishop e2 and
he's good can you believe it okay
so you can just slowly build up your
attack just getting this pieces out
Bishop threads the bishop it takes it
you're no reason to double the poems
alright so so look at this so so if
Jacob was playing like white you know
it's pretty much an equal position here
maybe white has a slight advantage
probably but it was that much okay right
so so the last thing black would want to
do in this position is break open the
center your king is in the center this
king is safe and castled right so so
ideas are like you know Bishop here
Knight f6 get control of that efore
square the last thing you want to do is
break open the center here so all right
so you get you get what you get some
Knight takes Knight takes Queen takes
and obviously well obviously we have two
good moves here right when we can
threaten checkmate drain checkmates
always good right love threatening
checkmate and then also a king queen on
the same file guess what we're going to
do pin right so rookie one excellent see
why could I'm not saying this is the
best move okay I'm not saying that okay
but we have ideas like this in this
position just take the pawn it looks
humorous but I mean you know we can do
it you know you're just by opening up
the center when your Kings there you're
letting yourself open to all kinds of
attacks okay yeah so game over okay all
right
take with check you know you might as
well just take it I would take I would
just play well no there's no reason to
take it let's just pile on right let's
see let's see i'm sure the rome piles on
right yet just pile on now get castle
there see it to ya too late too late
buddy yeah 3 late too late three leah so
and then the worst move well not the
worst move but it's pretty bad bill yeah
so now this is not back road checkmate
you can still play h6 or g6 here at but
now it's a alright so unfortunately that
moved i was going to show you that i
thought was going to be the worst move
did not compare to that move it was a
that was a stunner that's why why I left
out Jacobs last name so essa some kind
of animal minute II I remember I'm sure
Ben Simon will correct that when he he
looks at the cross table he's like yeah
it was Jacob so-and-so look who we have
oh it might be in a posture though a
perjury not adjourn hurry interesting
alright yeah it was a battle part for
the coolest name huh and obviously a
gern one because uh you know he went for
a no and won the title alright so so
it's a gas dear against a perjury
alright so let's check it out alright so
I gosh guys everybody should know
obviously is uh Wow was one of my
students ER or is currently he still is
all right all right he still is all
right great yes he is all white Agastya
21 so hopefully he plays a he plays good
here but this might be the game where he
makes the the worst move other than
obviously rook to e8 our work takes
that was even worse yeah I think this is
the game no right so so first off in
this position right right this is why
you always recommend hey move out your
King side pieces first already okay
because you know you want like that kid
as a room in the last game play Bishop
e2 here you know I might even play up
you don't wanna play Bishop here but
Bishop e2 might be fine Bishop here you
know what it doesn't do much and when he
goes here now you're just wasting time
and it's been fine gold says you know if
you're white and playing Bishop d2 you
know you're doing something wrong you
know and you definitely are alright so
that was his first mistake now Bishop to
d3 d5 so takes takes hopefully gets
castled here but he doesn't ok so this
is fine so now double attack I like it I
like it I like it so attack and neck guy
and that guy alright so so this is this
is one of the gaseous uh I don't think
he's going to blow this game alright so
now he's attacking a bishop he didn't
see that the other bishop was attacked
so let's see if you can figure out that
his light squared Bishop is attacked and
in think so think so so take take so
that wasn't your first round game
probably wasn't your toughest game
adjourn ok if a guy's just doing this to
him right secondly oh yeah okay yeah
okay all right good all right so so now
he's in a big bind here I don't know how
he's going to get out of it i would love
to hear from the audience to see you
know if they have any ideas here because
it's a joke how there's only one move
you can do to get out of it yes f 63
never play up six unless it's a
emergency but even f6 does that even
work it still fails to that right so and
if it plays night up six obviously we
obviously just resign right you're just
you're playing really bad and you're
giving a bad name to the perjury of
family I mean all right so it's all
right so so now that's that's a gas yeah
you know he didn't play the best but you
know if your opponent's just gonna hang
pieces guess what just take them you
know who won who do you think won in
this position right yeah right because
after mmm but oh man so I didn't see the
winning combination and the game I
mercifully continues sorry Queen to f3
Bishop takes Queen joy gotta you gotta
check in that was good so obviously
we're just bring the bishop pack and now
he's like okay now I were saying all
right so luckily I one thing go on down
much longer okay so let's check out what
uh zariah ms back up to cuz he did you
get the play of the ram in the
tournament he play Wilson in the last
round okay okay got it got it got it
okay all right so here's a here's around
he's playing black this time so we saw
him how he plays white pretty methodical
and so let's see how he does in s black
yeah right okay so II 4G 593 all right
so they're playing the Royal Lopez i
guess my legs why it is
oh so you're a lot of trouble so once
again you know you're playing too
aggressively in the center and guess
what you're going to get taken advantage
of real easily there's probably two good
moves here but ones probably way better
than the other yes yeah it's got to be
Queen D for the other idea is sack but
there's no reason to because you're
going to just win this night out right
so but those are just other ideas and in
the position but quindi for is way
better because if he tries to retreat to
defend it obviously we just will take it
for free alright so ideas like this and
then take and then take so so maybe uh
well this is pretty bad for a white as
well right I'm taking all your stuff
yeah so so those are some ideas to try
to try to recoup you know you're you're
missing piece but up up so
what did he actually play is a mystery I
guess this is how the game actually goes
okay so he did my joke recommendation
next to chief or and all right so takes
and we got three on one so just take
again and it's not looking good for for
white here he almost has the cake hey
alright so Queen f3 and we do not have
any smothered mates here but this is
going to be bad you're going to be in
that classic windmill position so check
night takes check so along the diagonal
here so now he should just repeat right
oh he needs to go back check so King
there check again check it again and
then you know you can do this forever
and then if you really want it you can
check again and then go tonight I've six
pretty mad as well get that extra pawn
okay but you don't let them out that
windmill so easy alright so negative six
so we stopped the you know Queen takes
f7 check button it always a rook checks
fish up up attacks the Queen so so you
know you're up you might as well I
consolidate you because you don't want
get checkmated alright so takes takes
rook e 2 so this should be a pretty
straightforward victory for black here
he's got three minor pieces and two
rooks and the guy only has two minor
pieces and it looks like he's up upon as
well
so now you know I know it gets Castle to
tax the pond here he sees it or she sees
that actually white is a as a lady and
show you a tax all right so this is a
this is an attack that there must be
dealt with now what's the easiest way to
deal with this k 5 right gotta be a five
but first he plays Bishop the f5 I don't
think I like so after rook takes rook
takes a five unbelievable I'm thinking
he's going to play h5 here okay it's
going to be a race you're too good a
journey you're too good you're too good
now even better than me and zhou room
combined we had two moves and you got
the winning boot yeah okay so yeah
obviously uh so let's check out
something though well okay there's only
one thing to consider here after Bishop
takes ok I'm going to take adjourn ok
and if you try to save your Bishop here
but i think i think you're going to be
too slow how does that make you feel
yeah 11 I'd be pretty upset right now
right all right
and then why it's making a comeback
that's why I mean it's so easy in this
position right you know he made a simple
threat a for right oh I'm going to play
five and he's like oh I got all these
cool cool little moves when the easiest
thing to do especially when you're up is
just to avoid complications with a five
okay but okay so takes takes a five rook
takes eight rook takes a eight and then
I have a five he's in trouble so Bishop
takes a five okay so that was the Rams
whole point then all right so he takes
so he does get the night back anyway so
maybe this around had it had it figured
out all alone so c4 so trying to remove
the defender of a c7 so Chloe wants to
put him in the in that windmill
oh yes sir okay let's see how we exploit
because this Bishop has a covered right
now okay rook oh yeah that looks pretty
good Kevin so yeah once he he removed
this vendor that's square nine up five
looks like a slammer because obviously
you know Ricky seven and boom boom yep
there's no there's no good a good
reputation to that good catch alright so
but he's got he's well he's thinking
about his own checkmate as well here so
Rick takes check he walks into the
windmill
and now check and the night takes with
his own check see so so because that
double check is a discovered check right
she discovered check blacks King isn't
checked by the bishop so when he
captures the bishop now he is in check
following so so white you might you
might as well get the bishop for it
right and then yeah yeah it's pretty
complicated position so he took with
check he purposely walks into the
windmill knowing that she's probably
going to play here and the night takes
with his own check and so we cannot take
the rook because the bishop is
delivering that check and now you know
it's it's reasonable and that's exactly
what white does alright so let's see so
let's see the game Wilson who came in
second to to adjourn how he does against
Agastya yeah so Agastya get paired
against Wilson was the number one seed
right yeah yeah okay so so this was a
pretty a pretty bad move that I was
played by Agastya and fortunately it's
not a quote-unquote blunder but it's
just a positional a nightmare here that
we want to see okay so I gasps who's got
the white pieces and they're playing the
sicilian exchange variation everybody i
seen this a million times not you okay
that's fine okay so Bishop ends the
night a bishop up protects it so Knight
takes Knight
that's fine and sewn up Bishop to b4 or
c4 which unfortunately is the five but
I'm sure Wilson okay both Wilson's just
gonna play you might as well if you can
ever play a d5 in the Sicilian without
having to play d 6 you're definitely
doing something right so that's what you
really want to strive for so is in check
it blocks the check so check so
everything's going pretty good for a
gastro right now he can just cancel the
safety and everything will be fine right
and that's what he does excellent okay
so blacks your castle alright so so
let's hear maybe some ideas for white in
this position anything you know in this
position you know our nights doing okay
our bishops doing okay we could play a
great move h3 and now we have to worry
about backrub checkmates we could play
rook to e1 you do all kinds of great
stuff okay but instead he doesn't know
what to do unfortunately in this
position so when you don't know what to
do what do you think you do trade pieces
okay so in this position right where we
could play h3 rookie one you know or we
could play like push pun took Queenie to
maybe and then get our rook on d1 you
know yeah a lot of great ideas here but
unfortunately when he takes here I mean
look at that look at blacks bishop in
this position not very good right look
at him now he's a monster okay so so
that was like one of the worst moves you
know even though it doesn't look like
it's like oh he's just try a three point
piece for a three-point piece you know
it's a really bad positional move for
him and now he's going to just
deteriorate because this Bishop is on
the the long diagonal and he's going to
crumble
of it so rookie one so right off the bat
the bishop could take and [ __ ] his
pawn structure which might be okay but
but Wilson knows my bishop is a monster
so up even though I'm going to get that
advantage I want even more so work a to
be eight so what tacking the pawn that's
you know protecting the night so we
can't play things like be three so
what's the most embarrassing move you
think agosta has to make the defend the
the pawn here yes Rick be one or queen
to see one let's see which one he picks
all right work the b1 okay yes her Queen
to be one Queen to be one does not work
adjourn right why doesn't Queen to be
one work because obviously Bishop takes
the night and bone work takes good point
okay so rook be one and just pile on so
now Queen to d3 does black have a tactic
here see what the OL computer says about
rip takes be too
oh yeah okay so I just want you to keep
piling on Oh 94 so in this position
right why should just try to get out of
all this nonsense with 94 excellent
suggestion yeah and that way he's kind
of out of this dreaded scenario
excellent all right so Queen to c6 quick
to c3 and now it's not going to be good
for him because he just like in the in
the first example I showed from the
National Open he just vacated you know
the back row you can't vacate that back
row when that's why white should have
played h3 when you didn't know what to
do yes Queen takes c3 yeah it doesn't
matter Bishop takes c3 is probably the
best yeah all right and now you know all
because you know agosta you know I said
up playing age 3 or just putting his
rook on a nice file he just had a trade
and led to a disaster and now look this
Bishop is still being like he's the MVP
of the game and and in a gas Joe these
are all unforced errors by him Black has
done nothing special in this in this
game obviously he saw the idea just pile
up when he had the chance after that but
I gasp you made the trade got the bishop
on the long file then he puts both his
rooks on the same diagonal as a as the
black Bishop and uh and he pounces so so
interesting so so black is already up a
full piece here
you could take a look for free let's see
if it wouldn't matter you need to just
you should be able to calculate that
that it's fine right let's see what the
computer says here but he should easily
be able to calculate that that's fine
Bishop takes c 1 is plus 10 h 6
everybody loves 86 is a plus 6 okay yeah
anyway that Bishop is so good he might
as well keep it and there's gonna be a
pretty easy endgame for him to win he's
doing everything you can to avoid the
back row checkmate here and and this is
just it's just like mop up time here I
apply to play rook takes g2 here or
whatever and that's the slammer you know
the work can't take because he's in a
pen and queen and let's just see how he
checkmates them real quick
all right hmm what do you like what do
you like adjourned yep attack the pin
piece he's going to get them in a mating
net here and then he's just kind of
checkmate oh yeah but your way your way
pi would have worked just as well right
so Queen f3 here right so weights king
really can't move right you're just as
good you just are you may be even better
all right much pretty a bishop checkmate
you don't see those every day if you
take a look at this position right Black
is crushing here all right and black is
going forward up up the board okay to
make it even more confusing of what's
going on all right so so look at this so
this is something that you know fine
goal has been really harping on lately
is um you know you have all this extra
material right you know if you're even
in a game right there's no way you would
ever trade you know a nine-point piece
for a three-point piece for no good
reason right but when you're up so much
material you're like I don't care I yet
you know I got all the riches I can just
start throwing it away it's a really bad
practice to get into and in this
position it's a black to move and it's
maiden name ok you probably get a queen
and then you just get another Queen and
then boom you game over ok but you'll
see how you know it's a Scholastic
tournament you know his dad's probably
watching it's like look at me i can i
can just like just humiliate the kid
okay so that's really not a good idea so
in this position here's here's how the
game concludes ok so it's black the move
it gets a rock you know who wants a
queen right so he boobs
so yeah I just take it whatever you know
I don't you don't need that pie yeah I
got it okay so so just check them just
just to be funny right okay so it's like
oh I get this guy so he moves attacks
the pond and guess what i just take it's
like why are you playing like this I
mean there's no reason and he ends up he
adds up getting the the checkmate but um
you know why wide right do all that
stuff you know just you know if you're
promoting get a queen you do not have to
sacrifice you know that rook that he got
for that pawn because that fun was a no
danger of becoming a queen right cuz if
he the only way he can become a queen if
he takes so in this position right you
just just March it up right and get a
queen and just win so so promote to
Queens don't mess around don't give up a
five-point piece for a one-point piece
then a nine-point piece for a one-point
piece there's a time to clown around and
that's after the chess game not during
it okay so that was the Royal Rumble
bash here's a some of the winners here
we got some photos here that obviously
is not the winner of the world of bash
all right here's a gas to deWine's older
brother adi he did well in the event
there's a Jonathan Trent's right over
there or my by a faithful uh substitute
and here's a here's that get the kid
that if you can figure that one out
that's a kid that just likes us a call
this pieces in the end game to the
humility is a permit who else we get
there's a Wilson all right
time and of course the champion of the
Royal Rumble bash and they actually
decided to take the picture where they
can actually tell who he is there's a
journey for the championship good job
adjourned all right and I okay so
hopefully we learned some stuff today I
certainly did thanks a lot everybody
you